We all remember that day.
There's only one way
this kid goes back out there,
and that's on a very short
I need to do more.
I can save lives.
When I was a kid, I always wanted to be
my dad.
people of Earth.
Put me back out there.
You're way too good for me.
Mark isn't like other vote from us.
He's a good guy.
Who are you?
I call me the Shape Smith.
I'll shut it down or I'll take it down.
there's an infinite number of dimensions.
And I was born with the ability to access
all of them.
Marcus, you have no idea how much
I wanted you to say this Me?
You can don't care how old he is.
He needs to go down now.
Maybe if you train more
and complained less,
What if I become him
and I don't even know it?
make him pay for what he did to you.
I need
The last 20 years of my life
have been alive.
You want this man come and get me
so arrogant.
Just like your father
The more you resist, the worse this gets.
And if you think you can stop us.
Don't forget. Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There's a brand new Invincible season 2
trailer, so we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of new footage
teasing the storylines
for at least the first half of the season.
Like, there's a bunch of stuff
that we don't see in here
we know will happen during season two,
but they're splitting the season
into two halves, like for and for.
It's all explain what's going on.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll do like an invincible themed giveaway
when the episode videos start in.
I will be doing weekly episode videos just
because they're releasing them weekly.
So it's a little bit easier
for me to do that this year,
they'll be dropping the first
four episodes from the season in November,
and then next year, sometime early next
year, they'll be dropping the other four.
because there's a lot of angstrom
levy footage in this trailer
in a lot of events
from his comic book run.
they might wind up beginning the season,
mopping up the mess left
over from the end of last season with him
trying to get back in here
with the Guardians of the Globe
in seasonal
and trying to help people
basically clean up
a lot of the messes that his father
created.
Omni-Man tie up a lot of loose ends
and lesser villains
and then get to the Angstrom levy plot
and spend most of the first half of the
season on that.
then there might be some sort of angstrom
levy cliffhanger in episode four.
And then when they pick up in the second
half of the season next year,
Then they might resolved angstrom
levy plot and push to conquest in a Nyssa.
like the next two really,
really big villains after Angstrom levy.
But Angstrom Levy seems like
it's going to be a big part of this first
half of the season.
There are a ton of new characters
that they announced in the last trailer,
so I'll talk about them
as they appear in this trailer.
We don't see everybody that
they announced, but they start the trailer
on the wreckage of this city
with them talking on the news
about the aftermath of Omni-Man attack
and what happened.
but here's the thing.
They're kind
of juxtaposing these two footage
like the city damage is not from that news
broadcast.
We'd like two completely different scenes.
this scene of the widespread damage
is actually from another universe
with another version of Invincible
who winds up taking over the planet
with his father,
like he says, yes to Omni-Man.
And they both team up
to take over the planet
for the big termites
that's because the angstrom
levy plot, like he's
one of the big villains
this season, is a big multiverse villain
like the invincible version
of a multiverse plot
Robert Kirkman was like,
I hear everybody's getting tired
of the multiverse stuff
in the Marvel Universe.
Don't worry.
The way that we treat multiverse
in the invincible universe
is going to be very different.
If you read the comic book run
that you know
some of what they're going to be doing.
but they will tease a bunch of alternate
versions of Invincible, where things went
down differently in all three universes,
like in the main universe.
He obviously stood against his father
and said no to the villain termites
taking over the planet.
there'll be some very big consequences
to that.
When the adult termites retaliate.
So we'll get to that in a second,
don't worry.
But before that is all the angstrom leave
his stuff.
He's not a build from. I.
So we're basically starting the trailer
looking at the wreckage
of what happens when Invincible tries
to take over the planet with his father.
But in another universe, it's meant to be.
From that same scene
at the end of the trailer
where he's on the read out
display on their version of Times Square,
basically telling the people of Earth
to give up because he is invincible.
But they do that title treatment
where he almost says the word invincible,
but then it cuts to the title
screen Invincible.
And if you think you can stop us.
Don't forget I'm.
That's
one of the evil versions of him
from another universe.
when they're talking about
on the man's betrayal on the news.
They juxtapose some brand new footage
with footage left over on the news
from season one.
Invincible travels back to the site
where his father almost wound up
killing him but couldn't do it
because his father still loves him.
So a big part of the invincible
storyline is still omni-man,
even though it's mostly about Invincible.
He's the titular character.
a lot of the continuing story
of Invincible.
Like for however many seasons, it
winds up burning for the entire comic
book run is the story
of the redemption of Omni-Man.
So he is going to be on a redemption
arc eventually.
It'll just take a little while
to get there.
not much time is meant to have gone
by since the end of season one.
so this is all still fresh wounds
in everybody's mind.
like Mark's
blood is still all over the rocks here.
It hasn't completely dried up yet,
The other noticeable thing that you see
when you're watching the trailer here,
not anything about the actual story,
but the actual quality of the animation.
Seems like he got a huge a huge upgrade
like Amazon
pumped way more money into this.
Robert Kirkman even teased that they're
developing a live action invincible movie
maybe we'll see Jeffrey Dean
Morgan in that because he was reading
the Invincible compendium
books from the comic book storyline.
But that might be because he's
coming to the animated show to play
a version of like Frag or Conquest
or like another big character.
Jeffrey Dean
Morgan would be a badass version of Frag.
Invincible starts reminiscing on
wanting to be like his father, basically
dealing with the grief
in everything that happened.
Like he's still kind of shattered inside,
not sure what to do about everything.
Then he starts wondering if he is going
to potentially betray everyone.
Like what happens if he turns evil
like his father or winds up being evil
like his father is a very Luke Skywalker
Darth Vader kind of thing.
Like, am I going to become like my father?
There's a potential there,
but it's all about the choices you make.
In a big part of
that is the people around Mark
or the invincible character
that help him be good.
mostly his mother, Atom Eve,
like his relationships with his friends
just in general.
All the positive influence around him.
and this is also a big part of redeeming
the Omni-Man character.
It's all about Mark.
But Mark is the person who helps make him
want to be better.
there's a couple of scenes
throughout the trailer of him
trying to go on saves
like he's talking to Cecil.
Please put me back on the team.
I want to help.
And Cecil isn't quite sure yet
because not that much time has gone by
since that season one finale.
Like, we're still kind of worried about
you because you're part built for Mike.
That's why you see him
fighting the Immortal.
Because the immortal hates
the termites, hates Omni-Man
and doesn't trust Mark either.
There's a much bigger storyline
with the Coalition of Planets.
They're introducing those characters
and that comes through.
Alan The Alien character.
Basically he's trying to pull for Mark,
like he's telling the coalition of planets
like, No, no, no, he can be good.
Don't worry, he's on our side.
this is basically the headquarters
of the coalition of planets,
this is the Thaddeus character.
He is huge played by Peter Cohen.
so the idea is that
Thaddeus is a huge character
in the history of the invincible universe.
He's like an O.G.
built termite
that goes back to the original war
that cleansed their people
of all their weaknesses.
And when he's talking about like
I haven't seen this kind of destruction
since the last Great War,
remember built from ice
just gets stronger as they get older.
So theoretically they could live forever,
which is why he's so old.
But what wound up happening
is that when their race started,
their internal civil war
to make themselves stronger,
they started conquering
the rest of the universe.
Eventually he saw that is a great evil.
He saw their people as evil
and rebelled against them.
in the aftermath of their people's
supremacy, he became the first rebel
against their people.
The first bill tried to go against
the united bill to my people.
during episode eight.
Alan the Alien explains to Invincible
what the Coalition of Planets is basically
an anti bill tramite coalition of planets
that want to get rid of them
and stop them from conquering
the universe.
Thaddeus was actually a founding member
of the Coalition of Planets.
their lives, begin the season.
And he's still with the Amber character.
I don't know how long
that's going to last, There's a lot
we can talk about there, but like it
kind of gets into spoiler territory.
if you know about what happens
between Invincible and Atom
Eve don't pose that in the comments below
worry we can talk about that
in like the second half of the season
that becomes a much bigger thing when
Conquest and Aeneas wind up showing up.
But that's like later, later in season
two, maybe even beginning of season three
the Guardians of the Globe meet the Shape
Smith character
he's played by Ben Schwartz.
He sounds familiar, like,
that sounds like the voice of Sonic Sheep.
SMITH Obviously, as you can see from
the footage, is a shapeshifting character,
kind of like Morph.
This character floating in the background
with the Guardians is bulletproof.
He's another new character
during season two, played by Jay Pharoah,
this is the Angstrom
Levy character working with the Muellers
to construct his multiverse device
these scenes in the trailer
are right out of the comics
with Invincible
showing up to try and stop Angstrom.
Libby
basically creating an even bigger mess
and turning angstrom Libby
into an even bigger villain for him.
The collateral damage from what happens
here is the reason why there's this
giant globe over this part of the city
here, like it causes this giant explosion.
the way they cut the footage
makes it look like
Mark is punching
another build from right here.
But that doesn't happen yet.
Like he does wind up fighting
other village termites Eventually.
But if you look at this scene, it's
actually another vulture might fighting
this build might like it's
to build termites duking it out so.
It might be another flashback or
it might actually go to the Voltron Planet
this season in present day,
but it's a little bit early for that.
I'm not expecting that
till like a little bit later in season
two, maybe beginning of season three.
This is Mark fighting dog seismic
in a lot of the other villains
from the end of season one that they tease
and all those different post-credits
scenes.
of the beginning of season two is him
cleaning up those messes, like
just trying to be an actual superhero,
getting the public
to try and trust him again.
this is actually a big twist here, too.
This scene here is a little bit
misleading.
It's angstrom levy after
he's been disfigured by invincible,
dumping him in another universe
where he actually tried
to take over the planet
like an evil version of Mark,
try to take over the planet.
So everybody on that earth hates him.
And he basically takes the regular
invincible dumps in there and tells them
that this is their invincible.
Get your revenge on him
as much as you want.
So one of the big things during
the season is Mark
trying to make it back to his universe.
After Angstrom,
Libby dumps him in another universe.
this is the Kill Canon character
coming back.
They featured him at the beginning
of the Invincible series
as one of the first villains
that he brought in.
Also featured during the Atom
Eve flashback episode.
She was one of the first villains
that he bought when she was way younger.
So it's a big callback to see Atom
Eve getting ready to take him down again.
Like, I remember you.
You were that child
that I took down a long time ago.
This is just the immortal training
with Invincible.
Like he's not trying to kill him,
but he does kind of want to kill him.
the couple of new characters.
Mark seems like he's on another planet.
Hard to tell where he is in this scene.
You see him
post up in space next to a black hole.
That's how powerful he is.
Remember, he's only half will try to
So full built
termites
can actually become much more powerful
like frag Then, like I said, when he does
the big people of earth speech,
this is meant to be an alternate universe
where this version of Invincible
helped take over the planet.
Early theory that is probably the universe
where Angstrom Libby
dumps him when he sends them
to an alternate universe to just trap him
this is like the alternate universe
version of the Guardians of the Globe.
That's why
they look a little bit different.
there's a bunch of Easter eggs
and references here.
So if you think you spot
any that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
But we'll get some more footage
before the season actually premieres.
They also just released the trailer
for Omni-Man in Mortal Kombat,
one he's voiced by J.K.
Simmons.
And a lot of the scenes are references
to his scenes from season one.
Like a lot of his finishing
moves are references to season one moments
particularly the train scene.
the funny thing about that is that Ed
Boon said
the minute he saw Invincible Season one,
he wanted to put Omni-Man in his games,
but originally he was thinking
about putting him in the injustice game
would have been a totally different vibe,
He claims he felt like Omni-Man,
which is better in Mortal Kombat one.
The way that they're building this game.
maybe I'll give away a couple of copies
during my Invincible episode videos
click Here for my Invincible Season
two Bonus Episode Video for Atom Eve
and click here for my brand new Loki
Season 2 Episode 3 Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching, everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one1